eu agradeço as palavras professora
primeiramente gostaria de agradecer o
professor marcos e é professora valéria
pelo convite
estou muito lisonjeado de poder aqui eu
assisto muito ted ea a minha ideia que é
passar para vocês um conceito que a
gente vem desenvolvendo a nossa empresa
que é uma empresa de tecnologia é e como
é que nós vamos criando uma causa dentro
de uma empresa de software
eu comecei a desenvolver software com 16
anos profissionalmente já tem 26 anos de
experiência na área desenvolvimento de
software
eu não sou tão jovem quanto o professor
colocou aqui anteriormente dá pra ter
uma idéia da minha idade mas sempre
trabalhei nessa nessa questão do
desenvolvimento de software
já tive quatro empresas a primeira
empresa eu falei com 20 anos e destas
quatro empresas têm duas funcionando
hoje
então houve uma fala aqui que
experiências não tão positivas nos
trazem aprendizados e realmente isso
aconteceu nessa questão dessas empresas
e como nós trabalhamos sempre nesses 26
anos e trabalhei eu e minha equipe meu
sócio
sempre trabalhamos com um softwares
customizados
então o software customizado te dá uma
amplitude de conhecimento legal porque
nós estamos desenvolvendo softwares para
diversas áreas agronegócio estamos
trabalhando software para do direito
trabalhando software para a área a de
vendas e estatística quantitativa e
qualitativa entanto é sempre um desafio
já tem um desafio técnico desafio
tecnológico que ele é complexo trabalho
de software nós desenvolver um software
aplicativos já é complexo e nós temos
mais um ponto que é desenvolvimento de
software customizado diversas áreas e em
agosto de 2014
quatro anos atrás nós fomos desafiados
por um empresário aqui da região para
ajudar ele a crescer mais que tinha
chegado a um ponto que não conseguia
mais dar conta de decrescer não
conseguia mais a cobrar os seus clientes
vou dar um exemplo assim mas antes disso
o professor também colocou muito bem a
questão da lei nós temos hoje uma lei
federal que a lei 12.305 de 2 de agosto
de 2010
a lei que rege a política nacional de
resíduos sólidos no brasil e nela diz
que todos nós pessoas físicas jurídicas
somos responsáveis somos temos
responsabilidade compartilhada de tudo
aquilo que a gente gera ea clint destino
para nós pessoas físicas é mais
tranquilo
nós temos um município que é responsável
por coletar mas as indústrias as
empresas que geram resíduos industriais
alguns resíduos perigosos infectantes
elas têm um problema sério porque elas
podem ser responsabilizada por que um
transportador ou um destilador fez
alguma coisa errada com seu êxito
então assim e se esse problema ele pode
gerar multas inclusive detenções e
prisões futuras já aconteceu casos aqui
na região também de detenções em virtude
dessa dessa lei e ela está sendo
aprimorada a cada vez mais
então e se voltando o assunto do
empresário ele nos chamou e nós
encontramos essa imagem aqui uma pilha
de papel é uma empresa de logística de
transporte de resíduos privado
o primeiro focar no empreendimento que
está fazendo registro privado depois eu
vou pra pessoa física e nós olhando
aquela pilha no início não entendemos e
nos explicou que aquilo ali era um
relatório que ele tinha que digitar né
dentro da sua empresa para poder cobrar
os clientes
e aí o que nós é bom tem um problema que
vamos entender melhor esse problema que
a gente fez
fomos andar com os motoristas coletar
resíduos
fomos lá verificar como trabalhava e aí
nós segundo porque da pilha vamos pegar
empresa com 25 veículos
ela tem um motorista e um auxiliar cada
um deles precisa de um roteiro onde vai
dizer os 10 15 clientes que ele tem que
visitar e cada um deles tem que ter o
endereço nome
o resíduo que tem coletar e ele vai
aquele papel volta então um dia 25 vezes
2 a 50 10 dias a 520 dias da amil 30
dias da 1.500 a gente tem essa pilha e
só que ela não é tão bonitinho assim o
pessoal coleta resíduos né então as
folhas são amassadas a escrita de uma
forma que é quase ilegível
vezes e aí é onde que nós entramos com
uma solução
nós entendemos um problema e propomos
para esse empresário olha quem sabe nós
como empresa de software nós gostaríamos
de ter um produto
nós vamos investir nesse nessa solução e
vamos criar um aplicativo para o
motorista de vocês e vocês não vão mais
usar papel bom foi que ele fez em um ano
em cheio o aplicativo pro por empresário
aqui da região
só que nós queríamos vender esse produto
obviamente e para nós ter um produto
comercial
nós tínhamos fazer muito mais coisas pra
colocar isso em escala que nós fizemos e
continuamos trabalhando em dois anos de
trabalho começou em 2006
nós já tínhamos no nosso software
rodando com o aplicativo e 10 mil horas
de trabalho e qualificação ele tem o
código modificado 10 mil horas parece
assim para uns pode ser muito ou pouco
mas vou dar uma ideia uma dimensão sem
pegar uma pessoa e trabalhando
dos 180 a 200 horas - a quatro pessoas
daria 800 mil horas em um ano a gente
teria 10 mil horas em dois anos
só que a gente chamou a equipe vamos
conversar um pouco quanto tempo demora
pra ter uma versão boa robusta comercial
já estava sendo validado para os
clientes ea equipe não precisa de mais
10 mil
tudo isso feito no capital próprio não
estava ali querendo resolver um problema
mais 10 mil e aí eu e meu sócio fábio
nós paramos vão conversar e aí surge uma
oportunidade muito legal na nossa vida
que foi poder participar de um programa
de empreendedorismo na universidade
tempo no vale do silício na califórnia e
foi que nós fizemos nosso que nós
fizemos os cálculos o investimento que
nós teríamos em em em despesas de viagem
inscrição e tal não chegaria nem perto
do que tinha por investindo no futuro
nós decidimos então e pra lá ser
sabatinado tinha que ter uma idéia eu
tinha que passar por um intensivo de
três meses num vídeo conferências
acontecendo aqui no brasil eles estavam
lá mentores nossos estavam lá um dos
mentores foi fundador da intel
das pessoas que estavam lá então nós
fomos preparados pra ser sabatinados la
stampa
então nota a essas fotos que tem aqui
são todas elas já deu na universidade
nós passamos uma semana de sabatinas ão
que quer fazer lá eles querem destruir e
foi tentar fazer com a gente e foi a
intenção que foi é pra lá porque se
essas 10 mil horas não resolver seus
problemas por resolver outro vou morrer
aqui então vamos ver se outros
só que ao contrário o pessoal ficou
muito surpreso
da forma que todo mundo trabalha hoje na
parte de gestão ambiental
a gente pode pegar grandes
multinacionais a gente pode pegar grande
universidade e lá na área ambiental como
trabalha hoje que a ferramenta tem hoje
corporativa não tem a maioria não tem a
maioria usa o word excel outlook mandei
email tem planilhas excel ninja com 200
mil fórmula para gerar o gráfico e tal
tá na mão de uma duas pessoas e essas
empresas estão usando e softwares porque
está funcionando a área ambiental está
lá e o que nós percebemos que era um
negócio e o que a gente fez
voltamos lá de tempo uma certeza de que
estava no caminho certo
continuamos trabalhando mais um ano e
meio e aí nós ti
nós tivemos e desenvolvemos a nossa
versão comercial para logística e
transporte
então agora com o software para o
motorista auxiliar em vez de chegar lá
com o papel anotar e chega com o
smartphone
a gente conseguiu aumentar a autoestima
do pessoal o pessoal chega lá com o
smartphone é coisa eu posso dizer que
está internacionalizada software
isso é coisa de primeiro mundo como a
pessoa que vai coletar o resíduo lá no
consultório médico consultório
odontológico tatuador na farmácia que
usa um software de se ele chega lá com
um uniforme dele eu quem tiver no
exterior com um tablet e um smartphone
vale fazer a coleta registra a
informação no tablet bate foto do que
está coletando pega a assinatura no
tablet e emitir um recibo vai embora e
não tem papel
esse dado é transferido para a empresa e
empresa fatura e né todo mundo feliz
porque eu fico assim e é essa área é
fascinante por
e esse pessoal que trabalha na área de
gestão de resíduos esse trabalho um
pouco o pessoal não dá muito recurso
algumas empresas dão mas na média estão
ali e vamos são os mal necessário tempo
que não consegue fazer o que a gente
tentou fazer desenvolver uma solução de
baixo custo para as empresas poderem não
digas empresa os departamentos e as
empresas de transporte poderem ter um
software com tempo para resolver o
problema deles
só que aí não para o problema aí nós
resolver um problema dos transportadores
aí nós temos geradores nos receptores
consultores ambientais continuamos
desenvolvendo
hoje a gente tem um software que atende
todos os atores da cadeia de transporte
geração de resíduo privado
nós não trabalhamos com ainda o governo
uma coisa que o pessoal não tinha o
tinha na verdade através de planilhas e
vários controles manuais nós conseguimos
centralizar isso uma ferramenta onde tem
gráficos onde tem gestão das informações
o que eu consigo tirar relatórios para a
fipan pelo ibama dependendo do órgão
ambiental estadual tá pronto lá alguém
pergunta a gente sempre fala tu tem que
conseguir se defender do órgão ambiental
da auditoria com o nosso software não
precisa acatar uma planilha não sei
aonde não sei que quando isso não
precisa o software tem que entregar isso
e esse foi o nosso verde essa foi a
oportunidade que nós como empresa de
software criamos um produto hoje
hoje ele é um software que a gente vende
uma média por uma mensalidade ea gente
já tem clientes na como geradores
transportadores consultores ambientais e
receptores um cliente quem está em
plantão se ter uma idéia existem 600
caminhões
imagina 600 caminhões 600 planilhas que
eram feitos manualmente e nós estamos
resolvendo problemas cliente com nosso
software que é específico para a
operação de gestão de resíduos
o que eu fico mais feliz é que agora em
abril desse ano de 2018 esse projeto
vira uma empresa então é uma empresa
hoje um software é uma empresa e tá
hospedada dentro do parque tecnológico
da universidade de santa cruz do sul
e gosta de falar isso porque nós fomos
uma das primeiras senão a primeira
empresa incubada em 2004 aqui dentro da
universidade eu tenho informação aqui
dentro da universidade então está em
casa e está gerando emprego renda e
qualidade aqui dentro da da nossa região
e nós conseguimos colocar esse projeto
dentro da universidade
só que a universidade é sacana elas
ocorram nos cobrou um projeto de
pesquisa que o culpado sair dentro de
nós tinha que fazer um projeto de
pesquisa mas nós tínhamos um outro
problema na gestão de resíduo que nós
não tínhamos resolvido e estava
engavetado e aquele problema entre aspas
é uma brincadeira obviamente se tornou
uma outra oportunidade
nós escrevemos o outro problema que a
gente tinha como projeto de pesquisa e
aqui algumas informações pessoa fugiu
ficar aqui mas eu tô mais pra cá não vão
voltar mas é a luz é forte eu queria
passar algumas informações para você
sempre você tem noção de quanto resida a
gente gera uma pessoa gera em média no
brasil um quilo de resíduo por dia uma
pessoa por dia nós fazer continha rápida
360 quilos num ano aí com 40 anos a
pessoa criou 15 mil um quilo de resíduo
uma expectativa de vida de 78 anos uma
pessoa gerou 29 mil quilos ou 29 mil 29
toneladas de resíduos
esses quatro caminhões estão vendo aí
não dá 29 mil quilos
então cada um de nós aqui vai gerar se
chegar aos 78 marcaram chique né eu
espero chegar um pouco mais mas cada um
de nós vamos ver a esses caminhões e
esse aqui é o caminho não será
compactado sim bem apertadinho nós vamos
gerar isso aqui de resíduos
só que a gente também se deu conta que
não são só esses resíduos que a gente
gera cada um e deve ter um quartinho da
bagunça um lugar que tem muito êxito não
sabe o que fazer e fica ainda molhada
mas onde é que vou descartar onde eu vou
descartar é mais ou menos isso aqui né
a gente olha ali aquele pneu ele onde é
que eu ponho aquela tv estragada aquela
torradeira elétrica teve professor aqui
que eu sei
em uma batedeira uma torradeira dentro
do carro há dois meses sabe enfiar e
isso acontece no dia a dia das pessoas
e foi aí que surgiu o nosso projeto de
pesquisa que estava engavetado
o que nós fizemos nós desenvolvemos um
software se chama ecomind esse é um
projeto social da nossa empresa que nós
estamos fazendo e liberando as pessoas
físicas de forma gratuita para elas
poderem entrar no software e dizer o que
eu quero é que olha por causa da bagunça
primeiro a eu tenho aqui sei lá uma
batedeira um eletrodoméstico
nós vamos dizer o lugar inicialmente o
ecoponto da prefeitura onde se esse
resíduo pode ser descartado
as prefeituras elas fornecem isso sai no
jornal saque mas essa informação se
perde então um software veio pra isso
como é que nossa nós estamos lançando a
primeira versão estão em versão beta
agora se você procurar os celulares
ainda seis pessoas deixem suas armas
se vocês procurarem celulares vão achar
uma versão beta como é que a gente
iniciou o projeto
nós temos uma pessoa na verdade que
ligou pra 140 prefeituras aqui no rio
grande do sul encontrou 72 só que tinha
um local de coleta ponto de coleta
ecoponto e nós inserimos eles todos os
manuais lá dentro do software então
santa cruz região todo o vale do rio
pardo sul do estado centro do estado
total mapeado mais uma pessoa ligou há
três meses ligando imagino ligada à
prefeitura pedir para falar com o
responsável da área ambiental pra
perguntar duas voltas na quadra e não
termina a ligação porque ninguém sabe
direito onde é que essa informação e nós
conseguimos de 72
essa é a nossa fase 1 a nossa fase 2 é o
que instiga a população cobrar a
prefeitura porque nós não deixar as
prefeituras entrar lá e ganham solicitar
um login e elas manterem os ecopontos lá
essa é nossa segunda fase para ser
orgânico através das prefeituras porque
nós não tempo mão pra cadastrar 5 mil
municípios 15 mil pontos ou mais
intensidade que tem 20 35 pontos
superavançados ea terceira fase vão ser
dá poder para as pessoas poderem
incluírem e
pontos que elas recomendo pontos
privados você vai descartar o óleo pilha
e tal e você vai ponto aquele lugar
nós vamos criar uma sociedade é uma rede
social na verdade do bem
as pessoas vão poder qualificar vão
poder se comunicavam pode fazer uma
coisa boa deve fazer fique mesmo
disponível vamos lá vamos vamos
descartar resíduos forma correta então é
esse é a terceira fase do nosso projeto
nós temos já empresas querendo apoiar o
nosso projeto e nós estamos indo atrás
de como a gente pode fazer porque
realmente é que vai trazer algo de bom
para as pessoas então assim esse
trabalho né de mapear e tal vai
acontecer automaticamente essas telas
que vocês estão vendo aí elas são telas
reais então nós já tiramos do do
software e obviamente que tudo isso que
a gente fez e agora está quase virando
uma causa da nossa empresa a gente fala
muito nós vamos investir somente está
falando muito em resina né pessoal
estava meio apavorado estão ficando
loucos só quer saber de resíduos carta
resíduo agora teve um colega ele botou o
pé no chão já estava olhando para o chão
se o meu ano não é lugar de copo então
assim sabe é uma coisa que vai te
contaminando a parte mais legal nessa
área é que as pessoas da área são
contagiantes
elas querem fazer diferença ela e e e
digamos assim com um pouco então tem
muitas vezes tem muito então fazendo ali
mas não essa área ela é contagiante que
as pessoas têm paixão que estão fazendo
claro que a maioria temos que ser chato
ouvir o chato eu acho que eu posso que
vai virar chato o ator não sei né então
é muito legal isso aí
mas nada disso teria acontecido se não
fosse os nossos funcionários né
os nossos colaboradores que também
acredito que não é uma loucura que é
realmente a gente tem que fazer uma
mudança e obviamente as nossas famílias
os nossos amigos que vem tentando
incentivar porque não é fácil porque eu
digo não é fácil as empresas que
transportam resíduos departamento de
resíduos o orçamento deles não são os
melhores
então esse cara tá fazendo milagre e
hoje até a pergunta se se alguém aqui
que está na platéia que pode ser que a
cita o vídeo já foi lá visitar a área de
gestão de resíduos industriais
sabe como é que é legal o trabalho faz
com lixo tal trabalhar com resíduo não é
fácil então eu só tenho a agradecer a
oportunidade que esse empresário nos deu
nos colocar diante dessa área ea todos
os envolvidos que a gente tem no nosso
processo né
muito obrigado
[Aplausos]